everyone continues to panic over kovad
the media pretend universal mail-in
voting is a great idea
and trump does another disastrous
interview i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
stand up for your digital rights take
action at expressvpn.com
now there is a real gap that has emerged
in reality it's a it's a rift in the
space
time continuum see there's reality on
the one end and this
reality basically says that covet's bad
it's risky you should be careful
also it says that despite reopening in
texas arizona and florida and despite
the fact that there were increased
hospitalizations and some
increased deaths that that number has
started to go down again
these data suggest that things are not
looking bad in places like new york and
new jersey
that despite increasing cases in
massachusetts you're not seeing an
overwhelming
wave of death that in fact this is a
virus that we are learning how to deal
with that the
treatments are getting better that
people are generally being more careful
and that while we should be risk averse
we should also acknowledge that it's
time to get back to something
resembling ordinary life that doesn't
mean go into extraordinarily risky
circumstances doesn't mean don't wear a
mask
it does mean that this notion we're
gonna lock down forever is very silly
right that would be the accurate way of
putting reality
then there's the hair on fire media
they're the politicians and that is we
are all going to die
you you personally are going to die of
covid sure you're 20 years old and
you've never had
a health issue in your entire life you
will probably die of covid not only you
all of your friends everyone will
probably die of covid
that is the only rationale i can come up
with for the way that politicians are
currently acting
see here's the thing people want
government to do all the things people
have this perverse notion that
government can save you from all the bad
things that happen
in the universe now government does have
a role when it comes to global pandemics
in ensuring for example that people
cannot enter from countries
that the pandemic is extraordinarily
prevalent and the government does have a
role when it comes to enforcing public
health
but the problem is the government is a
blunt force instrument this is true in
every area of life government is not
exact
government is fairly ridiculous and when
government tries to be fairly exact
it tends to fail so let me give you an
example so over the weekend
my sister-in-law got married the
restrictions that were put on the
wedding were ones that were going to be
voluntarily
undertaken anyway it was an outdoor
wedding as opposed to an indoor wedding
everybody was socially distance
everybody was wearing masks
in the little bridal gifts that you get
when you register for the wedding there
was hand sanitizers everybody was hand
sanitizing
the restrictions that were placed on the
wedding by the state of california were
things like you can't have a dance floor
okay i'm not kidding so it has to be
outdoors and you can't have a dance
floor because if there's a dance floor
people might dance
whereas if there's just an open field
nobody will dance which of course is
ridiculous because people have been
dancing for centuries without dance
floors
and there were restrictions that said
things like well you know you just have
to make sure
that there are there are shields around
everybody who is talking to one another
right you have to have the plexiglas
shields which is totally fine everybody
is doing that except they are also
outdoors and you're socially distancing
in other words government does not have
the capacity to actually do any of this
stuff
right the government is a blunt force
instrument sometimes you need a
blunt-forced instrument the problem is
the most blunt force instrument of the
government is the lockdowns the
lockdowns are a button
and basically when people say government
do something politicians just smash the
button
like a small toddler you just smash the
button and
it doesn't matter whether smashing the
button is merited it doesn't really
matter
whether they're actually countervailing
problems with smashing the button
government actors have now been
incentivized to smash the button at the
first available opportunity
which is actually quite bad because for
example
there are significant problems with
smashing the button
and doing it over and over and over
again for example the new york times
reports today
that the pandemic that really we should
be worried about
is the tuberculosis pandemic not kidding
the new york times has an article today
about the tuberculosis pandemic saying
people are not getting vaccinated
there's a study out today suggesting
that everybody being locked in their
homes has actually resulted in people
having weaker immune systems which makes
perfect sense
and this is actually the case during
polio people who are
upper income were actually getting polio
were getting seriously affected by polio
at a higher rate than people lower
income because people lower income had
their kids out playing in the streets
and that was building up their immune
system according to the new york times
it begins with a mild fever and malaise
followed by a painful cough and
shortness of breath
the infection prospers and crowds
spreading to people in close reach
containing an outbreak requires contact
tracing as well as isolation and
treatment of the sick for weeks or
months
this insidious disease has touched every
part of the globe it is tuberculosis the
biggest infectious disease killer
worldwide
claiming 1.5 million lives each year
until this year
tb and its deadly allies hiv and malaria
were on the run
yet now as the coveted pandemic spreads
across the world consuming global health
resources these perennially neglected
adversaries are making a comeback
pedro alonso director of the who's
global malaria program says covet 19
risks derailing all our efforts and
taking us back to where we were
20 years ago it's not just that
scientific attention has been
diverted from these other much more
deadly diseases in terms of global cost
equivalent 19 has to date killed
something like i believe three quarters
of a million people
in a variety of countries about 700
thousand people in a variety of
countries
tuberculosis every year kills 1.5
million people
obviously we've done a pretty good job
in the united states attempting
tuberculosis in a way we have not done
with covid19 but
there are costs to shuttering everything
in the world the lockdowns
have raised insurmountable barriers to
patients who have to travel to obtain
diagnoses or drugs
according to interviews with two dozen
public health officials doctors and
patients worldwide
fear of covid and the shuttering of
clinics have kept away many patients
struggling with hiv
tb and malaria about 80 percent of
tuberculosis hiv and malaria programs
have reported disruptions in service in
other words
lockdowns have consequences guys and
this ridiculous notion that you can lock
down endlessly and it has no
consequences either
economic or health-related consequences
you won't see an uptick in deaths of
despair you won't see an uptick
in other childhood diseases becoming
much more prevalent because kids are not
going
in to get vaccinated it's just not true
okay we have done the stupidest possible
thing you can do in public policy which
is single factor analysis
single factor analysis is where you just
say the worst thing in the world is
getting infected from covet what can we
do to stop getting infected with covid
and so you just mash that government
button
and as we'll see this leads to some
incredibly dumb policy like the policy
we are currently seeing
in new york we'll get to that in just
one second first
let us talk about the fact that hiring
can be complicated so you really do have
to take advantage of places that make it
a lot easier to hire
hiring is challenging there's one place
you can go where hiring is simple
fast and smart where businesses can
connect with qualified candidates
quotable co-founder gretchen hebner
experienced how challenging hiring can
be after unsuccessfully searching for a
new game artist
to grow her education tech company then
she switched to zip recruiter and saw an
immediate difference you can too
by signing up for free at zip recruiter
dot com slash daily wires if recruited
does not depend on candidates finding
you
it finds them for you by using zip
recruiters screening questions to filter
candidates gretchen found it easier to
focus on the best ones
and then find the right one in fact
after posting the job on zip recruiter
gretchen said she was surprised she
found qualified applicants so quickly
she hired a new game artist in less than
two weeks with results like that it's no
wonder four out of five employers who
post unzip recruiter get a quality
candidate
within the very first day so as we look
to replace our producer katie who's
decided to move on to greener pastures
with a better version of katie like
maybe katie has a sister or something
but we don't know if katie has a sister
so we're gonna have to go over
to ziprecruiter.com go try zip recorder
for free you can go to ziprecruiter.com
dailywire that is ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e-zip recruiter.com
dailywire go check them out right now
and make the smartest hiring decision
okay so as i say we are now living in
this alternative reality where reality
says
that things are not great but they are
also not the end of the world and this
alternative reality the political
alternative reality where we ignore all
data
we ignore actual hard data in favor of
overblown headlines that don't actually
convey a lot of information we just go
to the most ridiculous version of the
headline you'll remember a few months
ago there are all these headlines coming
out of new york
children suddenly being infected with
covid and having terrible terrible
reactions
you know kawasaki like syndrome
and nobody ever asked how many people
was it it was like 80. and were those
effects permanent no
but this led the news for literally a
week it led the news
right the the gap is really bad and that
gap is getting worse the gap between
information
and simply political coverage is getting
worse and worse
which is the reason why for example
there's a woman
over at msnbc who just quit a msnbc
producer who just quit and she wrote a
letter
basically saying the reason she's
quitting is because cable news is bad
for everybody
she wrote a scathing letter saying that
they block diversity of opinion over at
msnbc and not only do they block
diversity of opinion
they also avoid actually reporting good
information in order to do segments that
are likely to draw eyeballs
so all the incentive structures are
wrong our politicians are incentivized
to smash the lockdown button
in order to avoid blame our media
figures are incentivized to panic at
every available opportunity or
alternatively
to blithely dismiss the thing is not a
problem at all and you don't get any
good information
you still haven't we are now let's see
we lock down in march so march april may
june july
we are now in month six of lockdown okay
and you still
don't know much more about this thing
than you did originally because the
coverage here is just garbage it's just
garbage
okay and some of the scientists haven't
done poor job of conveying their
findings
but it is not just that it is also that
everybody is incentivized wrong so
perfect example of this bill de blasio
yesterday announced that outdoor dining
will be it will be the norm
in new york through next year through
next year
how the hell does he know he says open
restaurant
will return next summer starting june
1st
2021 next summer
not even like january 2021 june 2021
okay now i know i've got my calendar
here i i've been
reliably informed that today is august
4th so he's talking about
10 months of extensions to no indoor
rest
no indoor dining in new york what is the
data that supports this
seriously what's the data i get that
indoor dining
is more likely to spread kovid than
outdoor lighting is i've gone to
restaurants and done outdoor dining and
when given the option to eat indoors i
eat outdoors
i get it i'm on board but we don't know
where things are going to be in june
2021.
we have no idea where things are gonna
be in january 2021. we don't know where
things are gonna be in october
2020. the notion that you're going to
shut down all of new york city i mean
you know many bodegas are going to go
out of business because of this 15 000
small restaurants have already gone out
of business in the united states
in the past six months and they ain't
coming back and he's gonna ban basically
like there's not a lot of outdoor dining
in new york hate to tell you not a lot
of space in new york
it was one of the big problems with new
york city so here's bill de blasio idiot
communist groundhog murderer mayor of
new york this big weird frankenstein of
a human
saying that open restaurants will return
next
summer june 2021 as we'll see in a
moment
this is patently crazy here's bill de
blasio being a crazy person
these restaurants will be back again
next year
on the street as we've seen tremendous
success
starting june 1st next year and i wanted
to say it now because i want
people in communities to look forward
and see that we're going to keep coming
back
strong i want the folks who own the
restaurants to know that they're going
to have that additional revenue going
forward the folks who work in the
restaurants to know
that whatever else we have to weather we
have seen that this experiment
worked so expect to see that wonderful
outdoor dining back
next year we may even extend it further
earlier in the spring but we'll start
with june 1st for now
okay so we're going to shut down he's
saying we're going to shut down all of
new york basically for for months and
months and months and years and years
and years here's the latest data from
new york
okay here's the latest data from new
york okay the latest
data from new york let's look at some of
these charts okay so here's some charts
daily testing in new york okay here's
the positivity rate
the positivity rate so in april the
positivity rate on test in new york city
was
in excess of 70 this is for my friend
david bonson and the positivity rate was
in excess of seventy percent
it has been less than two percent since
june 16th it is currently at less than
one percent
the positivity rate in new york city
okay how about some more
charts okay we we have this one this is
the total number of cases in manhattan
okay in new york city there are over 6
000 daily cases
a day in april and by the way that is
wildly under counting because the
testing simply was not available
and so there are a lot of people who are
getting this and suffering with it who
are not being tested positively on
monday
there were 57 cases 57 cases
in all of manhattan in all of manhattan
okay let's look at hospitalizations in
new york city
in hospitalizations in new york city
okay
15 total covet hospitalizations
and this has been the case for months
four months since the beginning of june
you've been talking significantly under
100 hospitalizations
for covid in new york city we are now
down to 15.
okay and the mortalities just don't
exist in new york okay thank god
mortalities are just gone there are many
days of zero mortalities it is always
less than ten it has been less than ten
for weeks you are now more likely to be
shot in new york city than you are to
die from covet in new york city on a
daily basis
hey that is not an exaggeration that is
a reality you are more likely
today to be shot in new york city than
you are to die of covid in new york city
so when bill de blasio announces things
like the schools are only going to open
under certain conditions and we're going
to do it like two days a week and then
we're going to shift students in and out
and we're going to shut down all the
restaurants and we're going to make sure
that nobody dines indoors
like i have a question by what metric
would you actually be able to reopen
anything and the answer is
that by no metric because by that the
politics of the situation have
completely
taken over this is all insanity
again you can be cautious and you can be
and you can be smart
and you can be risk averse you don't
have to be an idiot but this is idiotic
okay lockdown policies like this are
idiotic meanwhile over in la
we are similarly deploying the lip we
won't shut down complete riots in the
middle of la street
so long as you are shouting george floyd
at the time but we will make sure that
lapd is deployed
to ensure that if somebody has a private
party in a mansion on a hilltop with a
bunch of 20 year olds
that the cops show up to break it up
because the last thing we want is a
bunch of 20 year olds getting covenant
being fine
that's the last thing we want and by the
way if you're 20 that's what happens you
get covered and you're fine
and i'm noticing that there haven't been
a lot of calls about racial profiling
here
okay this is tape from the mansion this
is just from i don't see any uh a lot of
white faces here okay there's a very
disproportionately
minority party okay no claims of racial
profiling here
the cops are fine apparently to go to
mansions and break up mansion parties
with a bunch of 20 year olds
even if those 20 year olds are people of
color right but if they actually go and
they stop people from breaking
storefronts on melrose boulevard
that's a completely different story so
lapd responded to a party at a mansion
and again you can see from the video
these are not 70 year old black people
right these are 20 year olds
who are in a pool this is what we've
come to
this is what we've come to does it seem
like intelligent policy to you
like seriously does it because i'm just
wondering how under what circumstances
is this intelligent policy
to you by the way it's not the fault of
the cops cops are bad except when
they're breaking up pool parties where
there's
zero risk of harm to 20 year olds then
the cops are good
yeah you know it feels like
what we really should be doing right now
is looking at the fact that everything
is trending the right way in places like
texas and arizona and maybe even
california california seems to have
peaked at this point
and we should be saying oh look there's
there's light at the end of the tunnel
and then it turns out that thanks to the
media and thanks to our politicians
that's just a train
coming down the other end of the tunnel
want a second we're going to get to our
stupid politicians on a national
level going at each other over over
kovid and all the rest
none of us giving us any sense of
confidence because that's what we do
where this is
everything is stupid we'll get to that
in just one second first let me ask you
something if there was someone out there
who kept a log of every single thing you
did
every minute of the day like santa claus
the naughty and nice list except not
bringing you presents but instead
monetizing your data when that creepy
out well what if i told you that that's
what happens when you go online
your internet provider at t comcast is
allowed to store logs of every website
you've ever visited and can legally sell
this data to anyone
that's why i always use expressvpn
expressvpn reroutes your internet
connection through their secure servers
so your internet
provider can't see or log what you do
online now some of you might be
wondering well if i'm routing all my
data through a vpn doesn't that just
mean the vpn can see what i'm doing and
log my data instead you would be right
to think about that many vpns claim to
have no logs policy but have been caught
logging customer activity expressvpn is
the vpni trust they use trusted server
technology
they were the first major vpn provider
to engineer all of their vpn servers to
run in ram which makes it impossible for
their vpn servers to store any data
including logs of any expressvpn
customer you don't have to take my or
expressvpn's word for it
expressvpn is so confident in their no
logs claim they even had one of the
biggest assurance firms
pricewaterhousecooper
audit their technology it's a good idea
to protect yourself from all sorts of
bad actors online expressvpn allows you
to do this
visit expressvpn.com right this moment
find out how you can get three months
for free that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpns.com
expressvpn.com
ben go check them out right now okay so
if you thought okay well at least maybe
there's some experts who are going to
give us some sort of
you know good information here and we
can trust the experts i am amazed to see
how many politicians
here's the way it works if trump says
something bad about fauci then he's very
mean and he's saying something bad about
an expert if nancy pelosi rips on debra
burks
then she's very good so over the last
several days for some odd reason nancy
pelosi has decided that deborah burks is
the enemy
a lot of female solidarity happening
here so yesterday nancy pelosi slammed
dr deborah burks who's been doing her
best in
under trying circumstances at best here
she was yesterday
and they said well we'll bring a
scientist to say that i said well
sure it's not dr burks because i don't
have confidence
and anyone who stands there while the
president says uh
swallow lysol is going to cure your
virus you know you'll kill you and you
won't have the virus anymore
i'm not i have confidence somebody when
the president says it's a hoax
it's magic it's going to go away by
magic it's a miracle and
all of those things okay so um i have
i have a question uh what does she
expect berks to do like go up and
physically tackle trump
i love the math here the math is trump's
doing a bad job therefore we need all of
his advisors to quit
and if you stand there and you try to
give him good advice that means that
you're bad then andrew cuomo got in the
act
he started slamming brooks too so that
was that was great here's the governor
of new york who completely blew it his
state is number one in terms of deaths
it is not close
and and here he was slamming dr deborah
burks
yeah look i think the the federal
officials the white house dr burks the
secretary
they're sending the exact wrong message
they've learned nothing in six
months uh they're saying the same thing
they said about the economic reopening
just do it just do it it will be fine
and what's really frustrating is we're
replicating the mistake with schools
that we made with the reopening it is
the exact
same point and the white house is saying
same thing okay there's a problem with
this dude okay he's such an idiot he's
such an idiot first of all burke's never
said
just do it second of all the notion that
the re-openings are the cause of the
vast spikes
that doesn't actually match up on the
timeline the protests might look much
more
like the cause of the vast spikes than
the original reopenings which happened
in may the uptick happened in july
it's a two-month gap and then beyond
that him suggesting that schools are
just like every other element of society
when it comes to reopening
is belied by the actual data which
demonstrates that schools have not been
vectors of transmission in nearly any
country they have been tried even in
israel it's not clear
why exactly the schools became a vector
for a transmission the best going data
right now
is that the schools were being seated
with people who already had coveted when
they went to school
they weren't clean they were just
walking in with kovid already
okay so berks fought back against this
she said she has tremendous respect for
pelosi but the criticism was
uncalled for and then she suggested that
things are still pretty bad which
prompted trump to hit her so
you know definitely what instills
confidence in our system
of public health is when public health
experts like berks
are ripped by the left and then ripped
by trump in response
to responding to the left and then
everybody doesn't know what the hell
anybody is talking about nobody can
trust any of the data because no data is
being presented in the first place do
you feel more secure
the great irony of this whole situation
is government has never exercised more
power in my lifetime than they are
currently exercising over american life
and abroad
and yet there's going to be an entire
group of people who suggest that the
answer to all of this is to give
government more power which is patently
insane have you seen the people who run
our government they're absolute
freaking morons have the combined iq of
a piece of bread
i mean they're they're total adults okay
i mean this like on all sides i'm
talking about like
this is not this is not a partisan point
the people who are in charge of your
life are some of the dumbest people i
have ever seen in my entire life
okay they don't know what in the hell
they're talking about and they're not
presenting good data that you can make
good decisions based on and they're not
making decisions that make any sense
this is all crazy talk so here is
burke's trying to do her best
you know kind of clapping back slightly
and nancy pelosi and then being slapped
around by trump
this is just i'm sorry this is all crazy
and if you feel sanguine about any of
this or if you think joe biden's going
to solve any of this that old doddering
none of it's going to solve any of it's
the train is coming down the tunnel guys
that ain't the light that's a train
i have tremendous respect for the
speaker i mean i have tenderest respect
for her long dedication to the american
people
and i think it was unfortunate that new
york times wrote this article without
speaking to me
this was not a polyanish view i have
never been called
polyanish or non-scientific or non-data
driven
and i will stake my 40-year career on
those fundamental principles
of utilizing data to really implement
better programs to save more lives okay
and this prompted trump
to basically say well we should be
pollyanna she's like
here so trump then tweeted out so crazy
nancy pelosi said horrible things about
dr debra burks
going after her because she was too
positive on the very good job we are
doing
and combating the china virus including
vaccines and therapeutics
in order to counter nancy deborah took
the bait and hit us pathetic he's
so now he's ripped vouching and burgs
like the two people who are out front
and he brought them out front now he's
ripping them
do you feel more safe and secure today i
mean that's that's really gonna be the
question
and if you're joe biden all you have to
do is sit in that basement and be dead
that's all you have to do
it's the easiest thing in the world all
you have to do is sit in the basement
and just be not alive
and people are saying right now why
doesn't joe biden get out there and do
interviews because why in the hell would
he
seriously why would he i mean the media
are playing cover for crappy democrats
across the country from bill de plazio
to andrew cuomo
to gavin newsom that they're doing a
horrible job the democrats it doesn't
matter
the media will cover for them the media
will cover for nancy pelosi when she
rips on deborah berks
and then trump will jump in with both
feet and just instead of him saying
nancy pelosi should respect public
officials like deborah burks who are
doing their best and nancy pelosi
doesn't know what the hell she's talking
about
instead he jumps in and smacks bergs
like this is
you wonder why people are feeling a
little bit disappointed right now why
people are feeling a little bit confused
the reason they're feeling a little bit
confused is because nobody knows what
the hell is going on and nobody's giving
them any good solid information
to make them feel like there is a plan
in any of this and that goes for all
sides
now again i think the media play a lot
of this up i think the media have an
interest in the chaos
i think the media liked the chaos i
think the media have engaged in panic
porn
if i have to see another story about an
individual anecdotal story of somebody
who got coveted
all i can say is that is the biggest
waste of space in a newspaper i can
think of
anecdotal stories about people who got
coveted are not useful data sets are
useful
it is useful for me to know what risk my
parents are at that's what i want to
know
i want to know why we are six months
into this pandemic and i still
don't know what the actual infection
fatality rate is for various age groups
and by precondition in the united states
how is that possible that's the only
question that needs an answer and we
still don't have that data what the hell
is everybody doing with their time
instead it's well if if ron desantis
didn't lock down then he's a very bad
man but if andrew cuomo did lock down
he's a very good man and donald trump is
bad and
deborah burks is good or she's bad
depends on who's ripping her at the time
this is all nonsense it's absolute sheer
nonsense and here's the thing
the fact that it's all chaotic out there
meant that if donald trump were a good
communicator
he could actually be taking advantage of
that unfortunately the president happens
to be
when it comes to anything that requires
any sort of simplistic data analysis
not very good at this okay and it's
really going to hurt him if you want to
see him winning
if you want to see him stave off joe
biden and the radical left you need him
to do better than he was doing
which brings us to this interview he did
with jonathan swan yesterday which is
just like i don't know who's booking his
interviews i swear to god i don't know
who in the comms office
is booking these interviews but like if
you're in the comms office and you're
like you know what
sit down with the best interviewer in
the business jonathan swan swan is is a
bulldog
i know jonathan a little bit he has a
long history john jonathan's a very good
reporter
hey j if if your answer was put the
president after after going on with
chris wallace
and you know having a dicey time sit
down with jonathan swann
jonathan swan morphed into john oliver
during this interview through no fault
of his own
and we're gonna get to that in just one
second again man
i'd love like a great news day it'd be
nice but we're just not gonna get one i
think we'll get to that in just one
second first
let's talk about the fact that it's now
a bad time to go to an auto parts store
rockauto.com
is much easier than walking into a store
and someone's demanding quick answers to
things like
is your odyssey an lx or an ex and then
they usually just have to order the part
online anyway
because there are so many types of cars
it's impossible to keep them all stocked
you have access to rockauto.com at your
desk and in your pocket
all the parts that you will ever need
available to you with the click of a
button
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices based on what the market will
bear like the airlines do why would you
spend up to twice as much
on the same parts unless you're a fool
rock autoduck you are no fool and that
is why
you have developed both an immunity to
iokin power and
a knowledge of rockauto.com rockauto.com
is a family business serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years head on
over to rockauto.com to shop for auto
and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers
best of all prices at rockauto.com are
always reliably low and the same for
professionals and do yourselfers why
spend up to twice as much for the same
parts the rockauto.com catalog is unique
remarkably easy to navigate quickly see
all the parts available for your vehicle
choose the brands specifications and
prices you prefer
that amazing selection reliably low
prices all the parts your car will ever
need go check them out at rockauto.com
go to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for that car a truck
right shapiro
in there how did you hear about usbox so
they know that we sent you
okay so all this brings us to the fact
that if the media are going to
lie about the situation regarding covid
which they have been doing through very
misleading headlines and through
political coverage and if democratic
politicians are going to smash that
lockdown button
and shut down entire school districts
without the data to back it up
if they're going to shut down private
schools that are doing their best to
protect
students if democrats have decided full
scale across the country that lockdowns
are the only solution that provides
an opening for president trump to be the
informational source right and this is
what you would normally expect from the
president
and i've said for a long time people
have asked me to grade trump a thousand
times and what i usually say is i break
it down into three categories one is
legislative policy
one is executive policy and one is
rhetoric when it comes to executive
policy i think the president's been an a
minus b plus president when it comes to
legislative
policy i think on judicial nominees he's
gotten basically an a minus
i think on everything else it's been
like a c plus because you get a tax cut
and that's basically what every
republican president does and then when
it comes to rhetoric i think he has been
absolutely awful in a variety of ways i
think that he's given like five good
speeches all off teleprompter but
one of your jobs as president is to be
able to communicate not only a sense
of stability to the american public in a
time of great chaos but also
you have to be able to in a very basic
way wade through the data right when
people say that ronald reagan was a
great president
they don't mean because he had great
spending policy they mean because he was
able to communicate
with the american public and to shift
people's minds in how they thought about
politics
donald trump does not have that capacity
and it is a problem in a time when
people are living
in justifiably great fear and some
unjustifiably great fear thanks to the
predations of a of a vastly polarized
media
okay so yesterday trump sits down with
jonathan swann of axios or he did this i
guess a week ago
and the video finally broke yesterday it
is just a bleep show i mean it's a bleep
show it is bad
it is a bad look for the president he he
it was the worst of him on display swan
is the kind of person who is not going
to let you get away with the sort of pad
answers that trump
usually gets away with swan is the kind
of interviewer who when trump says
things like
many people have said blah blah blah
blah swan will say which people
and then trump said many people say no
no i want to know which people and what
did they say
which is a completely fair question and
so there was a lot of that
in this interview and it was not a good
look for trump
it had some of his typical kind of
trumpian foibles you know things that
won't hurt him
but are not great so he was asked about
john lewis for example this clip was
going around yesterday he was asked
about the late congress person
who again was a very very liberal
democrat i disagreed with john lewis on
a wide variety of policies but his early
his early move his early action in the
civil rights movement is thoroughly
heroic
so jonathan swann asks trump a perfectly
predictable question about lewis because
this was recorded last week and lewis
just died
and trump proceeds to basically say he
didn't like john lewis because louis
didn't go to his inauguration
okay worth noting lewis did not go to
george w bush's inauguration
bush gave a speech at his funeral okay
but here was trump
looking petty is this a good look no
it's gonna hurt him not really but is
this a good look
no it's not john lewis is lying in state
in the u.s capitol
how do you think history will remember
john lewis i don't know
i really don't know uh i don't know uh i
don't know john
lewis he chose not to come to my uh
inauguration uh he chose uh i don't
uh i never met john lewis actually i
don't believe
um what okay so that's a terrible answer
that's number one a terrible answer
he didn't come to my inauguration and
that's the sole access along which you
uh
along with you judge somebody's entire
body of work that seems
wrong okay but that wasn't the real bad
point okay the real bad point is in a
time of lack of
understanding of covid and how bad
things are you actually have to have
some fluency with the fact
okay and as i mentioned when he was in
this this interview with chris wallace a
couple of weeks ago
he pointed out that the united states
actually has not performed all that
badly in terms of covet there are plenty
of other countries including the uk and
france that have performed significantly
worse in terms of deaths per million the
united states has ramped up testing
beyond any other country
by a long shot the united states is also
a federalist system and the great
failures in the united states
generally happen very early on in new
york new jersey connecticut they
represent something like 35 to 40
of all deaths across the united states
there are plenty of things that can be
said
the notion that trump was not early
enough on masks the conventional wisdom
is still divided on masks is the truth
virtually everybody in northern europe
does not wear a mask
they're not even masked mandates in
countries like sweden in countries like
finland
in countries like holland right they
don't exist cause there's plenty of
stuff for trump to say here when he's
asked about what have you guys done what
trump could say is the federal
government's job is basically a couple
of things one
trying to achieve a vaccine two trying
to shut down foreign travel and three
trying to ensure that everybody has the
resources they need
otherwise it's on the governors to
determine what needs to be shut down and
what needs to remain open
and so if there's a local failure
blaming that on the federal government
is mistake
have i gotten everything right
rhetorically no but i think as
information changed i changed some of
the things i was saying
i mean this is not all that difficult
instead you get this which
i mean i'm sorry this is just a saturday
night live sketchers jonathan swan
asking about the deaths in the united
states from covet and trump basically
just shuffling through papers handing
him a sheaf of charts
and then just being like look at this
chart and swan's like i'm looking at the
chart we'll just play the clip
oh you're doing death as a proportion of
cases i'm talking about death as a
proportion of population
that's where the u.s is really bad well
much worse than south korea germany et
cetera you can't you can't do that you
have why
you have to go by you have to go by
where look here is the united states you
have to go by the cases the cases why
not as a proportional population
what it says is when you have somebody
that has
where there's a case oh okay the people
that live from those cases
it's surely a relevant statistic to say
if the us has
x population and x percentage of death
of that population no versus south
africa
by the cases we'll look at south korea
for example 51 million population
300 deaths it's like it's crazy
you think they're faking their
statistics south korea and advanced
countries have a very good relationship
with the country
but you don't know that and they have
spikes look here germany low
9 000. here's one right here united
states
you're taking the number of cases okay
look we're last meaning we're first lost
i don't know what we're facing
yeah man okay so a few problems here
again what he could like there's so many
things to say when swan says okay south
korea has a very low number of cases
first of all
they didn't they didn't take china's
protestations that the virus wasn't
dangerous
seriously right they ignored china two
they were never seated with a heavy
number of cases
three they were infected with the asian
asian strain of the virus as opposed to
the european strain of the virus are
there a thousand things you could say
about south korea and when he talks
about germany germany was not heavily
seated with the virus
germany also has seen a worse economic
downturn than the united states in the
last quarter
so why don't you look at france why
don't you look at the uk when you look
at spain why you look at italy
and why you look at the again there are
a thousand things trump could say here
but trump doesn't have the fluency and
uh some of that's the fault of his team
that needs to inform him and some of
that is the fact that you don't
take you don't take interviews where you
don't
bother to do the prep not with somebody
like swan so does this
does any of this make it more likely
that trump is going to win election
right now
joe biden is just sitting there grinning
to himself because he can be as dead as
he wants to be
that's going to be the title of joe
biden's next autobiography that is i
want to be
and just be like a corpse you can be
like a barely animate corpse
you know being being rolled around on a
gurney not doing any debates not pick a
vp
and as long as trump does stuff like
that as long as his com teams rolls him
out for stuff like that it ain't gonna
be good
just there's such an opening here for a
president capable of conveying
information to the public and this is
why when trump was doing the early
pressers
on covet it was actually quite useful it
was quite good he was on point
but this was not the venue for him and
that is that is really going to hurt him
now
again he's operating in a context in
which the media hate his guts
in which people are trying to tear him
down in which they're frankly lying
about the performance of the federal
government again they keep saying the
federal government failed
every single democratic governor said we
asked for ventilators we got ventilators
we asked for testing they ramped up the
testing we asked for ppe they ramped up
the ppe
democratic governors from whitmer to
cuomo to newsome have all said this
and the media don't report that because
it doesn't go along with the narrative
that this is all trump's fault
but trump has to be better on defense he
has to be better at defending himself
and saying south korea is lying about
its stats
ain't gonna cut it and meanwhile
democrats are taking advantage of the
situation
in order to promote universal mail-in
voting again it is amazing the media are
just
i keep ripping on the media because this
is a time when you would have to have
faith in your institutions
to bring you actual relevant information
but the media are so in the tank for the
democrats and for every democratic
platform position
that they're just willing to ignore all
available data we'll get to that in just
one second first
let's talk about something you can do
amazing for your children so maybe your
kid's school is not reopening or maybe
it's only opening a couple of
days a week or maybe you're doing zoom
learning the reality is you're at home
with your kids
more than you ever have been and they
need things to read but you don't know
which books are best for your kids let
me tell you about an amazing amazing
service i love
this service i use it for my kids it's
just terrific
it's called literati it's the
subscription book club that makes it
easy to find unique
thought-provoking books for your kids by
delivering great stories straight to
your doorstep
literati knows that home deliveries are
critical for meeting your need for
uplifting educational tools
in the in the coming weeks reading books
together helps create a time of
adventure and bonding for your family
and has real educational benefits
kids who read books have better
vocabularies longer attention spans i
can tell you
my daughter loves literati she's six
she's reading at fourth grade level she
is
she loves it she's super into it also
i'm bragging on my daughter each
literary box contains five beautiful
books based on a theme
contains exclusive original art and a
personalized note to your kid
i promise you every time i get a
literary box my kids like freak out they
are so into it
literati literati actively curates the
stories that spark curiosity and promote
independent thinking
saving you hours of searching the store
or scrolling through a list of mediocre
books online and
literary does beat the amazon list price
then you keep your favorites you send
them back the rest back for free
which means you're only paying for books
your kids will love for a limited time
go to literary.com
shapiro for 25 off your first two orders
this is the best offer available
anywhere
to get it you have to go to literati.com
for 25
off your first two orders literati.com
shapiro go check them out fantastic
service
now we're going to get to more of
everything in just one moment democrats
continuing to claim that universal mail
and
voting is the solution and the media
echoing that despite the fact that
the data show this not only isn't a
solution it's a serious problem
i'll get to that in a second but first
if you are not yet a daily wire all
access member you are missing out gang
all access it's our most exclusive
membership tier featuring
behind the scenes access to us the
podcast hosts as well as writers and
special guests
all access members are also given early
access to new daily wire products as
part of that
i'm excited to announce our brand new
limited count collector's edition
baseball bat in collaboration with
pillbox bad company check
this beautiful baby out oh yeah it is
handcrafted right here in the united
states emblazoned
with the daily wire logo right there and
this run of bats they will each be
engraved with the individual number in
the order they were produced from one
two one hundred the bats currently only
being offered to our all-access
membership tier so join or upgrade now
before they are all gone
text the keyword baseball to 83 400
we'll send you the link to check out
this limited collection
edition bat and now if you're not yet an
alca access member coupon code access
will get you 20
off right now all access members you
also get to participate in all access
live that's where one of the daily wear
hosts
hang out with you for a live discussion
sunday it's a great live stream the
daily wire zone jeremy boring watched
the return of the spacex dragon capsule
and crew with all access members host a
discussion with them
afterward i'm doing one tonight again
text the keyword baseball to 83
400 to purchase your collector's edition
bat get 20
off all access right now with coupon
code access that is baseball to 83 400
coupon code access you are listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show
in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so let's talk about mail in
voting so the the democrats are now
pushing
voting by mail and the suggestion is
again anti-science okay the suggestion
is just as with schools they keep saying
the schools must remain closed they must
remain closed
first of all let me make clear i think
there are a lot of teachers out there i
got some emails on this yesterday i
think a lot of teachers who want to
teach
a lot of young healthy teachers who want
to teach and and understand how
essential they are in the lives of
children
and are treating themselves as essential
workers in the same way that essential
workers treated themselves as essential
workers
and we keep hearing teachers are
essential workers yes the essential
workers worked
right during the pandemic essential
workers went to work teachers are
essential enough they should also
be going to work just as cops went to
work just as firefighters went to work
and
let's be real about this teachers are
generally at less risk
than our firefighters or cops or even
amazon workers in all likelihood because
they're dealing less with adults and
more with children
okay so that is one area in which the
media have just been utterly
irresponsible in their coverage of the
data
another area we keep hearing that we
need to vote by mail that if people have
to wait in line to vote this is going to
cause
massive spikes in covet the evidence
just ain't there
it ain't it's in the same media that
will tell you that you can protest in
the streets with millions of other
people
with no mask and breathe all over each
other while shouting and be safe as long
as you're saying social justice warrior
things
is telling us that if you stand in line
four feet behind another person
and then you go and vote that you're
going to die of covid
okay there's one problem this is not
true it is simply not true
according to the cdc after
after 19 000 people voted in person in
milwaukee april 7th which was the middle
of the spike
14 tested positive for the virus 14 out
of 19
000. according to the cdc report from
milwaukee
there were no spikes in cases anywhere
else in the state due to the election
either
according to elizabeth good spokesperson
for the wisconsin department of health
services
71 people who tested coven 19 positive
throughout the state after april 9
and developed symptoms before april 21st
reported they voted in person or worked
the polls on election day
but several of those people reported
other possible exposures as well
so it's not accurate to say that the 71
cases were the result of in-person
voting because some of those infections
probably came
from other sources a total of 413 000
people voted in person statewide
in wisconsin april 7th although a much
smaller number of wisconsinites
participated in protest marches
following the killing of george floyd
wisconsin officials are aware of 28
confirmed cases
reported attending a protester rally
during early june during the two weeks
before
getting coveted 19. so the notion that
voting in wisconsin
was like a great threat to public health
it just was not true
it just was not true but that doesn't
matter democrats are pushing mail and
voting why because democrats
love mail-in voting mail and voting
combined with ballot harvesting gives
them an advantage
in many different districts if you
remember back to the 2018 election the
early reports in the night
you can go back and watch our coverage
we live we live streamed it the early
reports
is that democrat were the democrats
would have a good night but it wasn't
going to be a wave
then over the course of the next 10 or
15 days a bunch of late-breaking votes
came in from california
thanks to ballot harvesting and seven
different congressional districts that
had been republican flipped to democrats
and it became a wave
that was because of ballot harvesting
ballot harvesting is this idiotic
and what should be illegal practice
where you have third parties come and
pick up your ballot for you that are not
impartial
so the democratic party sends out a
person to pick up your ballot from you
which basically means that the better
funded the party is the more ballots
they're going to
be able to pick up they're going to
ignore everybody else who didn't get the
ballot off in time but they make sure
that your ballot gets in also if you
hand them a blank ballot
they are a democratic operative and by
the way you've seen the same thing
even in uh even in i think there's a
district in north carolina where
something similar happened
voter fraud is a thing okay it is to
pretend that it does not exist and the
possibility does not exist
counters a significant number of cases
in which it's pretty clear
that it has had a significant impact on
america's future most obviously when al
franken basically stole ascendancy from
norm coleman
in minnesota after 350 ballots were
discovered going for al franken in a car
like a month after the election in any
case nancy pelosi says that voting by
mail is a health issue again there's not
evidence
there's not evidence that if you stand
in line and socially distance to vote
that you have somehow raised your risk
dramatically of contracting the disease
here is nancy pelosi
basically lying here right now
even more important because it is a
health issue people should not have to
choose
between jeopardizing their health for
the coronavirus
and being able to exercise uh their
right to vote
okay so yeah again you are not being
asked to jeopardize your rights vote you
can request an absentee ballot
but the idea of universal mail in
balloting because of the pandemic
if you want confusion you want insanity
definitely pursue this the post office
is terrible everybody understands the
post office is garbage at its job
when it comes to ensuring that things
get there on time
how many times have they lost things in
the mail like a lot right
how many times have like if you move to
a different state
you will probably still be forwarded a
ballot from your home state
and that is a thing that will happen can
you imagine it'll take months to
tabulate how these votes are going to go
the house oversight committee according
to the ap has invited the new postmaster
general to appear at a september hearing
to examine operational changes at the
postal service
that are causing delays in mail
deliveries across the country the plan
imposed by louis de joy
republican fundraiser who took over the
top job at the postal service in june
eliminates overtime for hundreds of
thousands of postal workers and orders
the mail be kept until the next day
if postal distribution centers are
running late representative carolyn
maloney new york democrat
said the september 17th hearing will
focus on the need for on-time mail
delivery during the ongoing pandemic and
upcoming
election now can you just imagine how
bad this is going to be
so chuck schumer the senate minority
leader he says the mail delivery must be
timely
um i'm i mean has he lived in the united
states with the post office for any
prolonged period of time
stuff gets lost in the mail really
really regularly and is not supremely
timely which is why fedex
fedex exists here's chuck schumer
basically tacitly acknowledging that the
post office is not going to be able to
do this
we democrats believe strongly that we
have to have free
and fair elections that the mail must be
delivered in a timely way because so
many more people are going to vote by
mail
so many more polling places need to be
set up
because of coverage can't be close
together
okay again if you think that the post
office is going to solve this problem
good luck to you mike pence pointed out
yesterday that if you can you can still
apply for an absentee ballot if you want
but mail-in universal mailing is right
for fraud this is obviously true
jimmy carter had basically suggested
something like this 20 years ago he was
the vice president yesterday
let's be clear though laura absentee
balloting
is perfectly acceptable you have to
apply for an absentee ballot
signatures are checked it's confirmed
it has a long tradition and we want to
encourage any american that is not able
to go to the polling place for any
reason
to apply for an absentee ballot today
but this universal
mail-in voting where you're going to see
literally ballots
showered all across the state uh it's
just
it's it is right for fraud and and we
are headed straight
uh to the courts to put a stop to it
okay
definitely what would be best for the
country is if we have a contested
election
in which we don't know the result for a
month and nobody has confidence in the
results
and yet democrats seem pretty sanguine
about this james clyburn representative
south carolina says listen there'll be
some fraud with almost anything like
nearly anything that'll be fraud i mean
like so who cares
the president of the united states
expressing his opinion
about mail-in voting
it's not the facts the state of
washington
has been doing this forever and they
have found
that there's almost no fraud you will
have fraud
in almost anything yeah fraud in almost
anything is not an excuse for making it
easier to commit fraud
my favorite part of this is joe biden
from his basement claiming that trump is
going to try to claim the election is
rigged
okay we've now had several year what
four years of democrats claiming the
2016 election was rigged so it'll be
great
everybody will have no confidence in our
public health system because we have no
idea what's going on
we will have no confidence in our
electoral system because we have no idea
how people are voting
it's gonna take a month to figure this
thing out everything's gonna go great
guys it's all going to be
fine don't worry everything is good
everything is good
meanwhile if you want to make sure that
we we have no confidence in what happens
going forward
the media coverage of particular ugly
police incidents is not going to is not
going to make
anybody in the united states more
sanguine i've been warning for months by
the way
to take an example i've been warning for
months that the george floyd prosecution
the prosecution of the officers in the
george floyd case
is likely to go sideways if you want to
see officer derek chalvin go to jail
then probably they should have filed for
an assault charge right
he knelt on george floyd's neck for
eight minutes you can say that he was
negligent right
you could try to make a third degree
homicide claim they're instead going for
a first degree homicide claim i believe
a second and a second degree a homicide
second degree homicide i think is what
they're going for
which requires like an actual
willingness to kill somebody
okay there's no evidence like the
evidence on that is extraordinarily
scanty
you might be able to go for negligent
homicide the tape demonstrates
however that none of these guys thought
that they were killing george floyd or
even thought they were being negligent
about killing george floyd so yester the
reason this comes up is because
yesterday the daily mail leaked
more of the tape from the george floyd
arrest like the minutes leading up to
the
the eight minute tape that we've all
seen that horrible tape of derrick shaw
kneeling on george floyd's neck
okay the media should have covered this
responsibly from the beginning
by including all the details because
maybe that would have led to a
non-overcharge
there are a few things in the minutes
leading up to george floyd that the
situation we've all seen with derek
schalvin with his
knee on george floyd's neck there are a
bunch of things in the minutes leading
up
that cut against the homicide case
against derek shavin
okay so just to sum these up one the
police when they arrest
george floyd they tried to talk to him
they tried to be nice to him they did
this for many long minutes
second there were other people in the
car which i was not aware of i didn't
realize floyd wasn't in the car alone
and those other people didn't resist the
cops they didn't resist arrest and
they're fine
they're standing off to the side talking
to the talking to the police and they
are completely fine
third you'll hear in these clips that
george floyd
is begging begging and not to be put in
the car he says he would rather be on
the ground than in the car
and he is saying i cannot breathe before
he is even on the ground
now this does mesh with the original
state autopsy report which suggested
that the cause of death was not
asphyxiation
the problem with a homicide case is you
have to prove proximate cause you have
to prove
that the cops actually caused his death
but it seems a lot more like
at best stress exacerbated an already
bad medical situation when they arrived
he was not lucid
when they arrived he was already acting
wild and claiming he could not breathe
the reason i'm bringing this up is not
to say that you should be allowed to
kneel on somebody's neck for 8 minutes
the reason i'm saying this is because
when the media do not cover these cases
and include all of the fact pattern
what you end up with is a belief that
these guys will definitely end up in
jail
and then it turns out that the fact
pattern is a little more complicated and
they may very well get off
so if you liked the riots last time
around wait until the officers
are acquitted because of the
prosecutorial overcharge brought by a.g
keith ellison
in minnesota here's a little bit of the
tape that was released yesterday the
media are not covering this tape
because again it cuts against a lot of
the case that's being made namely that
the officers
knew that floyd was dying and
disregarded everything again
he was claiming he could not breathe
when he was sitting in the car okay
which suggests that when he claimed you
couldn't breathe lying on the ground
they were going to take that with
exactly the same level of seriousness
okay here is here's a little bit of the
tape
oh i see your hands
stay in the car let me see your other
[Music]
okay so he doesn't put his hands on the
wheel and he does then once he does the
the officer with his gun drawn puts the
gun back down
floyd is basically begging the officers
in this tape i mean it's all terrible
floyd is begging the officers i don't
want to be hurt they're saying we're not
going to hurt you everything's fine
and everything was fine until he
resisted arrest which does not justify
the actions of the officers but
makes it much more difficult to claim
premeditated murder which is what
they're trying to claim basically
okay then he says he doesn't want to get
in the car he says and they're saying to
him
we'll open the window for you they're
saying we'll open the window for you
we'll make sure that you can breathe
right these are not the actions of
officers who deeply do not care about
george floyd at least up to the point
where he's on the ground right and
actively resisting arrest
here's a little bit more of the tape
please pack it uniform
please stay with me man thank you okay
okay
the car because of claustrophobia and
because he was in fact high on fentanyl
according to the autopsy reports
again the point here is not the officers
did the right thing that's not the point
at all
the point is the media's irresponsible
coverage of situations like this is
going to lead to revelations in the jury
trial that may end up with the acquittal
of the officers
so you should be made aware of this
before you actually get to trial the
media instead largely ignored this
yesterday
which suggests that they're going to
cover this in the same way they covered
the michael brown trial
they're going to suggest that michael
brown was wrongly shot even when the
evidence
went the other way and then the officer
ended up being exonerated now in this
case
george floyd should not have been
treated that way by the officers an
assault charge was probably more
justifiable on the grounds that have
been put forward
so this is you know again
the wonder wonderful job by by the media
all around
here wonderful job by the media okay
we'll be back here later today with two
additional hours of
content we will also see you here
tonight for an all access
live in the meantime go pick up a copy
of my book how to destroy america in
three easy steps
we'll catch you in a little bit i'm
benchmare this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
supervising producer mathis glover and
robert sterling assistant director pablo
wydowski
technical producer austin stevens
playback and media operated by nick
sheehan
associate producer katie swinerton
edited by adam syavets
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
president trump appeals to the silent
majority joe biden's handlers wanted to
ditch the debates
and the minneapolis police department
release body cam footage
of george floyd we'll get into all of it
check it out on the michael knowles show